defensive rookie of the year odds posted
by draftkings and to little surprise
chase young the washington edge rusher
plus 200 it means you bet 100 you win
200 if he is the defensive rookie of the
year but the one name that stands out to
me guys one of my favorite players in
this draft the jaguars second first
round pick edge rusher caleb on chase on
when you consider the help he has around
him especially if they keep yannick and
gawkway for one more season which they
very well may do i'm intrigued by what
he can do and it plus 2 000 you drop a
hundred you make two thousand bucks
that's not a bad a bad proposition for
chase on who i think is extremely
talented peter what do you think
yeah i would i think chase on with um
you know obviously with josh allen on
the other side could really be a big big
threat and i like that pick the guy who
i would pick right now is i'd pick zach
bond
the reason i'd pick zach bond he's uh
drafted in the what the third round by
the saints uh this was a guy who
everybody in the draft absolutely loved
uh
you know a lot of people look at him as
the next teddy brewski he is a plug and
play
pass rusher and it very instinctive
player a guy gets 32 tackles for loss
and
sacks combined
in the big ten
that is a great football player he'll
have a chance to do that early and often
i think the presence of cam jordan uh in
front of him is going to be huge i think
zach bond comes in and makes a giant
impact as a rookie
mike you look at the two linebackers not
named isaiah simmons you know you
support system i'm thinking of that when
you take a patrick queen or kenneth
murray linebackers on already really
good defenses they got a chance but i
think the one that jumps out to me with
your logic mike is javon kinwa i mean
how many he's not going to get
double-teamed in san francisco he's
going to have a whole lot of one-on-ones
with that defensive line and that could
lead to a lot of big stats
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports